from exclusive items to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between kfc in india and the us this
is food wars
[Music]
here in india we have two types of
chicken sandwiches a crisper and a
zinger in the u.s we have two chicken
sandwich options the chicken little
because it's little and of course the
kentucky fried chicken chicken sandwich
the classic now let's weigh them to see
how much they weigh
obviously
this thing has not been cleaned
in a very long time all right first up
the chicken crisper
our chicken little in the us weighs
next up the chicken zingo
240 grams for the classic chicken
sandwich
this thing is a work of art all right on
to chicken popcorn here in india we have
it in three sizes regular medium and
large
we're gonna weigh our large popcorn to
see how much we get
i actually really love
chicken popcorn
i have an idea we should weigh one
popcorn chicken and add that back to the
total my bad my bad they should serve
this in movie theaters
i don't want regular popcorn anymore
i love that they sprinkle in a bunch of
sesame seeds and it adds a nice crunch
to it
what sesame seeds we don't have that all
right you guys are lucky that sounds
really nice we only have one size that
going to the website and the kfc i went
to and that is this
how accurate these measurements need to
be really
oh it's so good
unfortunately here in india we do not
have mashed potatoes but that would be
pretty awesome we do have fries we're
big fans of them and they come in two
sizes medium and
large
and in the us we also have two sizes of
fries at kfc the individual for an
individual and the large also for an
individual let us now measure the large
to see how much you get
140 grams
[Laughter]
that's never not funny that's the third
time that's happened and it's always
funny look at that block of fries our
largest fry
is more than double their largest fry
here's our individual
150
our smallest is bigger than their
largest
in kfc india we can get our chicken in
six portion sizes
number one
the
single piece
two piece
they like to give you one breast piece
and one leg piece
kind four piece leg piece to top it all
off the leg piece on top as they say
like cherry on top no okay now we move
on to buckets we have four sizes the
first one is a five piece bucket that
comes with only leg pieces and also does
not come in a bucket for some reason why
kfc i want a bucket
next up we have a six piece bucket an
eight piece bucket and the largest one
of them all a ten piece leg bucket
that's a lot of chicken in the u.s our
kfc chicken comes in seven portion sizes
one which you can get a la carte
two-piece with a combo
three-piece with a combo
four-piece with a combo then buckets
that work okay we have an eight piece
guide pieces
the 12th piece
[Music]
and our largest bucket the 16 piece
ready julie
you get the idea
next up you're gonna need a drink to
wash all that chicken down here in india
we don't serve cups we just serve cans
we have pepsi seven up mirinda which is
an orange soda red bull and a pepsi pet
bottle however these will vary from
store to store in some places they might
not serve plastic and in some places you
might not get these drinks you might get
something else they also serve something
called a virgin mojito crusher which
they don't deliver unfortunately but
here's an image of it
refreshing
american drinks come in these following
sizes the regular which is 20 ounces and
the large which is 30 ounces and hey you
don't have there if you want you can
also get half a gallon bag of your
favorite drink of choice look at this
thing
it's convenient
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at kfc india that you won't get in
the u.s here's everything you can find
at a kfc in the u.s you won't find in
india take a look india take a good look
okay let's start with chicken in india
apart from the crispy chicken we also
get smoky red chicken
wow
i believe this is kfc's answer to
tandoori chicken if you guys don't know
what a tandoor is it's basically a
cylindrical oven that they light up
using wood fire or charcoal and it adds
a really smoky flavor to the meats or
breads that you cook inside of it i
doubt kfc's across the country have an
actual tandoor but
flavoring definitely smells like that
the marinade looks like that
oh my god
that's actually pretty good
you know what kfc
pretty good job
you have to remember kfc is competing
with a lot of mughlai restaurants across
every indian city and while this doesn't
have as much of that smoky char that a
lot of tandoori kebabs have
it has a lot of flavor and the chicken
is quite juicy
good job
it's super spicy though so if you're
somebody who can't handle spice
go a little easier on this one when an
indian says something spicy it's spicy i
believe you man i believe you that looks
incredible we unfortunately don't really
have anything too spicy on the menu for
the like chicken and the bone options
really the only thing that we have here
that apparently you guys don't have is
something that is like what i associate
kentucky fried chicken with is extra
crispy i don't know exactly what makes
it extra crispy but it is as you can
imagine crispier than the regular
chicken
extra crispy to me is far superior to
the regular way liquid chicken i think
it should be the other way around like
this should be the regular and the other
one should be like
half crispy you know what i mean this is
all this is way better all right let's
move on to chicken sandwiches here in
india we don't have an american chicken
sandwich but we have a zinger and a
smaller sandwich called a crisper cute
the crisper looks like it wants to grow
up and be a zinger someday they also
come in two variants a spicy crisper and
a tandoori zinger let's taste all of
them
oh it's pretty yum they've used a
different kind of mayonnaise here it has
a bit of sweetness to it and a spicy
kick at the end
and now for the legendary zinger um back
in the day there were only two fast food
chains here in india it was mcdonald's
and kfc and while mcdonald's had more
affordable burger options the kfc zinger
was so delicious it was always a treat
to eat
and it still is i love that they use a
whole
boneless piece of proper chicken in
there
delicious mayo it's so delicious okay
now let's try the spicy variance this is
the spicy
crisper look at this sauce
it's almost blood red i'm excited
oh my god
the sauce almost has a schezwan taste to
it next up the zinger but tandoori
i love the fullness of the chicken that
comes in these burgers versus you know
like a minced chicken patty in other
restaurants there's so much bite to it
so juicy tender that all sounds amazing
steph you're going too fast i have to
say those sandwiches look delicious and
i am jealous one sandwich you can get
here in the u.s can't get in india is
this little guy
the chicken little looks to be
like a chicken tender
in between
these tiny little buns pickles goodbye
[Music]
i could really get like five of those
slightly different from what you have in
in india so i'm going to use it as an
excuse to show it off yet again our
crispy chicken sandwich this thing the
original the bad boy
also with pickles hang on
get off of my sandwich but it has this
really creamy mayo sauce on it the bun i
love this
yeah
other chicken stuff
we got here you ain't got i'm already
getting loopy start over here nashville
hot tender chicken here this i think is
the spiciest thing you're getting at the
kfc menu and it'll be straight up like
i've had these before these are pretty
good they're really crispy julie you
want to hear that crisp again
not sure if it's made it over to india
yet it is called a chicken pot pie
that's a pie but instead of there being
you know fruit or any of the sweet stuff
you like
they fill a pie with chicken and what do
you think else is in your corn gravy
peas maybe i have no idea i'm not gonna
rip this thing open this thing
has got some weight to it this is a meal
right here this is not a side i don't
know where it is on the menu but
this right here the kfc
famous bowl and it is famous let me tell
you
nikhil if you're wondering what this is
someone at kfc was like how can we put
everything into one bowl and this thing
was born it is
mashed potatoes corn uh the popcorn
chicken
cheese and gravy
on a convenient bowl for you to eat
while you're driving
it generally does nothing for the flavor
is exactly what i would think this would
taste like
it's just a bunch of this stuff in one
bowl
yes in india you can get wings of the
kfc but our kfc in the u.s you can get
your wings sauced and we have three
different sauces honey barbecue buffalo
nashville hot
honey barbecue thumbs down this
buffalo's a lot more orange than i
recall buffalo bearing i cannot quite
place my finger on why suddenly my
stomach is killing it
do you see inside there
okay
on to the next one
bring on that food poisoning baby
um
yeah all these are bad
all right moving away from chicken
india's kfc actually has vegetarian
alternatives for all our burgers there
is a vegetarian
crisper a vegetarian spicy crisper and a
vegetarian zinger now while india has a
majority population of non-vegetarians
around 70
there is a huge vegetarian population
which is why a lot of fast food
restaurants have to make sure they have
a lot of vegetarian options on their
menu to make it more approachable and
acceptable for all people over here
there's also levels to vegetarianism
over here there are i will eat egg but
not chicken vegetarians there are i will
eat fish but not lamb vegetarians there
are i will eat the curry but not the
peas is vegetarians there are i am
vegetarian only on tuesdays vegetarians
there are i have made a promise to god
for this one month vegetarians there are
i am vegetarian so you will all be
vegetarian vegetarians they're the weird
ones and we try not to talk about them
which is why kfc in india brands itself
as just kfc there's no kentucky fried
chicken anywhere here because obviously
i'm not going to go to a place that's
named that if i'm one of these many
types of vegetarians one iconic dish
that you'll find on the kfc india menu
is
biryani and so kfc india has taken a
very bold decision to launch their own
biryanis if you don't know what biryani
is you are living under a gigantic
boulder my friend hey guess i live under
boulder because i unfortunately am not
familiar with biryani but i would love
to know more about it
hello i am christelle pereira and i am a
cook and a baker and you may know me as
a fine artist from the great british
bake off this is biryani now biryani is
a typical rice dish you find in south
asia and the way you make it is in
layers my dad is a biryani master at
home and the way he makes it is with
cooked rice cooked potatoes some fried
onions and a curry we like to go for a
mutton biryani but you can get chicken
or fish and in this case vegetarian
biryani we absolutely love it and we
always eat it as a family unit with a
lovely pot of cooling writer on the side
which is a lovely cooling yogurt dish
which goes really well with spicy
biryani and it's basically our
equivalent of a sunday roast because you
have it in a big pot and you all take
scoops and i actually don't think i've
ever eaten biryani by myself for one
person now
we have to talk about this kfc biryani
because for me biryani it's a home dish
you make it in a home kitchen it's
cooked by a family member and it's
cooked with love my first impression at
kfc biryani those two words just just
don't go together for me just to give
you guys context of what it's like to be
indian and eat a biryani at kfc it's
like being italian and eating a pasta at
domino's
got it thank you
continue they come in four flavors
number one classic chicken nice and
crispy number two popcorn chicken
number three the spicy red chicken that
i really enjoyed and number four the veg
patty which
it's so tempting to just push that to
the side because veg biryani
is already just a concept that we not a
fan of over here
but just for
just for now you can you can stay here
okay i'm gonna begin with the popcorn
chicken biryani which is just so
blasphemous to begin with
it's not a biryani
it's
i'm so upset right no
this one the spicy red chicken
has a bit of that tandoori vibe to it
they really try to over compensate with
the spices there's a lot of clove flavor
just to convince you you're eating a
biryani so
go easy on that curry
i could eat this like if i was hungry
not a biryani though that biryani looks
real depressing i am sorry but we do
have these exclusive side dishes which
are mashed potatoes i can't believe you
guys don't have mashed potatoes it feels
like this is like flagship stuff here
macaroni and cheese biscuits again no
biscuits
coleslaw
this
giant dish
of just gravy and of course sweet corn
new country new sauces y'all know what
that means
sauce talk
first one i mean the kfc sauce why this
isn't at every kfc internationally i
have no idea gonna load that sauce right
there
and it's like ketchup and mayo
that's really good uh honey barbecue
i know that tastes like
honey mustard
that's not your thing
honey
and of course you got classic ranch
not much of a ranch aficionado
but those are just okay
and oh i forgot about the hot sauce
julie
6 40 p.m
india does not have too many exclusive
dips in fact we just have a veg eggless
mayonnaise and a tandoori masala
mayonnaise it's time to taste
i'm using the same hand because here in
india we don't eat with our left hand
if you're wondering why commenters you
let them know
why don't indians
ate with their left hand
[Music]
well it's just mayonnaise so
good job on that
mayonnaise again with a little bit of a
sweet but also spicy kick to it i wish
we had more options especially
considering there are so many
different delicious chicken options i'd
love to be able to dip my tenders in
more sauces that is a weird sentence for
those of you with a sweet tooth we have
two exclusive dessert options chocolate
chip cookie
and this
chocolate chip
cake
what does this look
here in india we have two exclusive
desserts a choco mud pie and a coffee
mousse cake
ooh
boy
just look at this cross section my
friend
next up
coffee moose cake
yeah um
these are
pretty average as desserts
drinks drinks drinks
maybe my favorite part of the exclusive
section exclusive drinks again in the
u.s you cannot get in india mountain dew
i'm back baby
and if you're mountain dew fan such as
me
you know kfc has got the exclusive
mountain dew sweet lightning so mountain
dew sweet lightning is like peach
mountain dew it's really good it's
really good
i think this is a lemonade the u.s style
lemonade not like that weird uk sprite
lemonade
not so good from there you can also get
serum mist
and of
course sweet tea
whoa that's like really sweet oh that's
really good
exclusive drinks in kfc india we have
mirinda which is an orange soda and red
bull let's talk about miranda
this is a drink that really evokes
nostalgia 90s kids
really know what i'm talking about when
i say
mirinda
which country is getting the better deal
on its kfc let's compare a few menu
items to find out both countries offer
eight piece chicken bucket here in la
one of these goes for 19.99
if you order an eight-piece chicken
bucket here at kfc india it will cost
you
699.05 rupees
very specific which is currently 9.15 us
dollars that makes the american 8-piece
bucket 118 more expensive than the one
in india does making your meal a combo
help the us price out at all
take this chicken sandwich combo with
fries and a drink it will set you back
in america 9.99
the indian equivalent is a zinger meal
where you can get a chicken sandwich
some medium fries and a drink for
319.05 rupees or 4.18 us dollars in fact
the price difference is so great you can
get something called the ultimate
savings bucket for just 599 rupees or
7.88
and this contains
four pieces of hot and crispy chicken
six heart wings four boneless strips
three drinks and three dips
yeesh
in fact you can throw in a choco mud
pie's dessert and still get all of this
for much cheaper than the american combo
meal but is it really that cheap here in
india no because two thirds of india are
still under the poverty line and for
them this meal is still very
aspirational they earn less than two
dollars a day sorry to be a downer but
this is still a meal that is only
available to the really privileged here
in india
unfortunately kfc does not share a full
list of ingredients with the public it's
actually the same in the us all kfc
shares with the public is a list of
allergens so what do we know about kfc
well the kfc india website has a couple
of clues we know that all of our chicken
is farmed here and not imported and all
of it is 100 whole mussel chicken
that means it's made from whole pieces
of chicken and not cut together minced
chicken like you find in chicken nuggets
in fact the website says they have an
open kitchen policy and what that means
is anybody can walk into a kfc and
apparently ask for a kitchen tour and
you can go into the kitchen look at
everything and ask as many questions as
you want
i've never heard that in my entire life
an open kitchen pot i've worked in
several kitchens and i'll tell you
straight up i was in a kitchen working
and some dude walks in is like hey gotta
tour the kitchen i'd be like yeah here's
your tour there's the exits definitely
can't do that in the united states don't
go into kfc chicken and demand a tour
the kfc us website also gives us some
hints about the ingredients it uses over
here for instance all of our chicken is
raised on u.s farms to the usda and
fda's standards so that means there are
no added hormones or steroids in
american kfc chicken in addition to this
as of 2019 yum brands the parent company
of kfc stopped purchasing chicken raised
using antibiotics indian chicken farmers
were previously criticized for overusing
antibiotics as recently as 2018 the
bureau of investigative journalism found
out that a lot of indian farmers were
feeding coal steen to their chickens as
a growth promoter without any medical
supervision kolestine is known as the
antibiotic of the last resort holy
oh my god
they're so frightening and it's only
given to humans when other antibiotics
have failed so if we give our chickens
coalestin then the humans who consume it
might become resistant to it in fact
they can develop a antibiotic resistance
superbug and that's not good julie this
sounds like the plot to a horror movie
what is he talking about
that is terrifying
i'm gonna assume we don't do that here
and if we do
oh god
but when a report came out talking about
the ill effects of coalition india ended
up banning it completely so we're safe
from coaliston at last
we should also point out that the kfc
india website is in major need of an
update there is an faq page where people
have asked things like how many calories
does this chicken have or
sometimes i see red deposits in my
chicken
what is it
and for almost all of these questions
the answers are just filler text so if
you ask me what those red deposits are
i genuinely don't know that's
interesting let's take a look at this
website right now
is kfc providing healthcare to the
employees kfc responds standard dummy
techs ever since the 1500s when an
unknown printer took a gallery of type
and scrambled it to make type specimen
book what is kfc doing for the safety of
their staff
lauren ipsum is a simple dummy text of
the printing and typesetting industry
yeah they gotta update their site that's
pretty funny